[Música]
la controvertida estrategia kobe de cero
por parte de las autoridades chinas ha
llevado a que decenas de ciudades del
país estén bajo confinamiento parcial o
total ante un nuevo auge de casos de
coronavirus pero es la ciudad de
shanghai de 25 millones de habitantes la
que más problemas ha tenido para frenar
este rebrote de contagios y ha padecido
tal vez los confinamientos más rigurosos
el principal puerto de china sufre la
peor ola de contagios desde que comenzó
la pandemia hace más de dos años en la
ciudad de buján les doy algunos datos
para que mencionemos la importancia de
esta ciudad y de su puerto esta ciudad
es un centro financiero global es uno de
los puertos de mercancías más
importantes de comercio internacional
solo en el 2021 representó el 17 por
ciento del tráfico de contenedores de
toda china a través de este puerto pasa
el 27 por ciento de las exportaciones
del gigante asiático unos 47 millones de
contenedores fueron movilizados es de
hecho el puerto que más contenedores
manipula en el mundo por más de una
década ha sido el puerto comercial más
grande del mundo superando a singapur o
hong kong tiene 125 muelles y 19
terminales
el gobierno chino no solo está bajo
presión a nivel local dada la gran
escala de su economía local que apuesta
al consumo interno para recuperarse tras
la crisis que deja la pandemia el mundo
entero pide una plena activación del
puerto ellos dicen que están haciendo lo
que pueden
las autoridades del puerto están
haciendo todo lo posible para garantizar
el buen funcionamiento predispuso que
25.000 miembros del personal trabajarán
en el área del puerto bajo la
administración cerrada el ministerio de
transporte formó un grupo de trabajo a
dos para establecer un mecanismo de
programación diaria con los
departamentos de transporte de janzour
and we jin jiang y shanghai en el delta
del río yangtsé así como empresas
portuarias y navieras clave
los efectos de la demora en la operación
porque hago la aclaración el puerto no
está cerrado está operativo pero no está
a plena operación por lo que los
contenedores están regresando en sus
muelles y los barcos se acumulan en
altamar a la espera de poder atracar en
el puerto los procesos de carga y
también de descarga son demorados y así
entonces la cadena de suministro y de
comercio se ve afectada américa latina
no va a escapar a este problema que
podemos esperar en nuestra región
desabastecimiento de algunos productos
incremento en los precios de algunos
productos más inflación lo cierto es que
por más presión internacional que haya
por muy importante que sea el puerto de
shanghai para el comercio mundial china
está optando por atender a sus
ciudadanos para hacer frente a la
pandemia garantizar salud a los
residentes de esta urbe aunque también
le caen muchas críticas por las
restricciones que impone y por esa
polémica estrategia de tolerancia cero
contra el kobe 19 esa es una balanza muy
difícil de equilibrar atender a 25
millones de habitantes que están
expuestos al coronavirus o ayudar en la
recuperación de la economía y el
comercio mundial chinas alguna no lo
tiene para nada fácil y por eso vamos a
debatir o analizar mejor este tema y
para eso hemos invitado a alicia
garcía-herrero ella es economista jefa
de natixis para la región de
asia-pacífico ya se encuentra en la
ciudad de taipei que es la capital de
taiwán en unos momentos vamos a
establecer conexión con ella y el
montevideo en uruguay está nicolás post
ls profesor de economía política
internacional en el programa de estudios
internacionales de la universidad de la
república
ustedes también nuestros televidentes
pueden participar en este debate en este
análisis con todos sus comentarios y
preguntas los pueden hacer a través de
nuestras redes sociales no se encuentran
en facebook en instagram y en twitter
estamos como france24 guión bajo e s
sant y luego que en mi cuenta personal
les recuerdo que nuestra etiqueta es
numeral el debate efe 24 esperamos todos
sus comentarios y sus preguntas mientras
establecemos conexión con alicia le doy
la bienvenida entonces a nicolás que
está en la ciudad de montevideo nicolás
gracias por acompañarnos a esta hora
aquí en el debate de france 24 y quiero
preguntarle entonces por la
consecuencias inmediatas que tiene esta
lenta operación del puerto de shanghai
que pues no tiene una fecha estimada de
cuando vaya a terminar esta operación
especial que están teniendo a lo largo
de estos días y que se reactiven
plenamente la operación que podemos
esperar en cuanto a consecuencias en el
corto plazo
una buenas tardes es un gusto para mí
estar con ustedes
este fenómeno que estamos observando en
la ciudad de china de shanghai lo
primero que cabe la pena puntualizar es
que agrega un elemento adicional de
presión a otras cuestiones que ya venían
atentando contra el funcionamiento justo
a tiempo de las cadenas de suministro
que se empezaron a dar resentidas con la
pandemia del 19 en este 19 principios
2020 y que luego está la economía
mundial y por supuesto las las distintas
economías nacionales que la conforman
también se han visto afectadas por el
conflicto reciente que hemos observado
en ucrania
lo cual ha puesto nueva presión sobre
algunos precios y sobre algunos bienes y
servicios que se comercian a nivel
internacional a esto se agrega ahora
este problema del confinamiento day and
night justo en un momento en el cual
algunas de las dificultades más severas
al funcionamiento de las cadenas de
suministro se estaban comenzando a
gestionar de forma algo más adecuada por
lo que podemos pensar en al menos dos
canales un canal por exportaciones y
otro canal por importaciones
una presión en américa latina' el canal
de las importaciones es un canal que
como bien señalaba puede afectar los
primeros inflación fenómenos que ya
vemos que se estaban generando previos a
esta última disrupción que se pueden
acelerar por causa de este motivo en el
canal de las exportaciones por el
contrario uno esperaría a corto plazo
algunos efectos inflacionarios dada la
reducción esperada de la demanda china
entre otras cosas de alimentos o de
materias primas que luego se utilizan
para la producción este de ilícitas
plantas ubicadas en este país que al
momento están teniendo dificultades para
operar dada las restricciones a la
operación en el puerto de shanghai que
comentábamos así que cuál es el balance
neto bueno exactamente no lo sabemos
pero podemos ver por un lado este
tendencias inflacionarias desde el punto
de vista de la importación y algunas
tendencias de muy corto plazo estén
estacionarias y pensamos en el canal
exportador claro porque además esto está
sucediendo en este momento y no sabemos
por cuánto tiempo se va a prolongar esta
operación lenta en el puerto no sabemos
entonces la magnitud de las
consecuencias en el largo plazo pero es
algo que se va a empezar a presentar en
los próximos días creo yo a escala
mundial porque todo el mundo depende del
comercio y de muchos productos hechos en
china precisamente y nicolás ese atasco
en el puerto de shanghai me recuerda
también a otro momento importante y
crítico del comercio marítimo y del
comercio internacional y fue el bloqueo
del canal de suez que nos dice esto del
comercio marítimo a nivel mundial de la
economía como la estamos manejando en
este momento estamos dependientes del
comercio marítimo para abastecernos en
las regiones para recuperar las
economías es momento de mirar otras
opciones que análisis se puede hacer es
una muy buena pregunta y uno puede
observar un montón de debates académicos
entre los practicantes de las políticas
públicas que se están generando en torno
a estas cuestiones hemos visto durante
los últimos 20-30 años una tendencia a
priorizar cada vez más la eficiencia en
la organización de las cadenas de
suministro que significa la eficiencia
bueno tratar de mantener los menores
stocks posibles
para ganar en términos de logística para
ganar en términos de abaratamiento de
costos y eso bueno redunda y en este
unas cadenas más eficientes en menores
precios que llegan al consumidor final
pero por otro lado en el otro este plato
de la balanza tenemos la afectación si
se quiere más negativa en torno a la
resiliencia de las cadenas eso que es la
resiliencia bueno es la capacidad de
éste sostenerse de seguir operando de
seguir funcionando prende a fenómenos
disruptivos frente a fenómenos que son
difíciles de prever desde cuantificar
cuál es su probabilidad como el atasco
este que vivimos este el año pasado y
este nuevo este problema asociado al
confinamiento shanghai por lo que hay un
debate tanto a nivel académico como a
nivel práctico pero de la necesidad de
empezar a balancear un poco más esta
atención entre eficiencia y resiliencia
y poner un poco más de énfasis en este
segundo aspecto por supuesto que esto no
viene sin costos por supuesto que
esto implica reorganizar la forma en que
se han desarrollado los negocios en los
últimos años pero en la medida que se
sigan suscitando fenómenos como este que
bueno que se agregan a otros que ya
mencionábamos en la intervención
anterior esto lleva a que efectivamente
se esté pensando se esté debatiendo
respecto a la necesidad de fortalecer la
resiliencia de las cadenas aún a
expensas de bueno de éste y se quiere
ceder un poco en lo que refiere a la
eficiencia de su organización está
demostrando lo que nos deja hasta el
momento en términos económicos la
pandemia del cobi 19 que las cadenas de
suministro entonces no eran tan
eficientes como estábamos pensando que
es momento entonces de replantear las
porque hago la pregunta porque hoy
estamos hablando del puerto de shanghai
la pandemia no ha terminado los
gobiernos están levantando las
restricciones pero la pandemia continúa
mañana puede ser el puerto de singapur
pasado mañana el de hong kong luego el
de los ángeles el de san francisco o
cualquiera otro puerto alrededor del
mundo y entonces la cadena nunca
terminará de despegar por completo de
recuperarse después de la pandemia no es
momento como de buscar entonces
alternativas o hacerlas más eficientes
más cortas
efectivamente el debate es ese la
eficiencia viene dada justamente por la
organización de modelos de negocios del
justo a tiempo de que los insumos
arriben exactamente al momento de que
son necesarios para la producción de que
los stocks en los inventarios de las
empresas sean bajos para reducir costos
pero esto viene a costa de que viene a
costa de una menor capacidad de
responder frente a fenómenos imprevistos
como el que estamos viviendo y como los
que hemos vivido en los últimos años
entonces tal vez sea hora de resignar un
poquito de eficiencia en esa
organización que permite reducir costos
a nivel de las cadenas y privilegiar un
poquito más la resiliencia de las
cadenas si podemos hacer esto bueno
entre otros entre otras estrategias
podemos apostar al menos en algunos
segmentos a cadenas más cortas a cadenas
que privilegian a los proveedores
regionales proveedores más cercanos y
también este a privilegiar otros
formatos productivos que se vienen
desarrollando con todo lo que tiene que
ver con el debate de la industria 4.0 de
la impresión 3d que pueden facilitar la
relocalización de ciertos procesos
productivos
en los últimos años han tendido a
localizarse en asia principalmente a
expensas de lo que son otros centros más
tradicionales como centros en américa
del norte europa occidental mismo en
algunos países de américa latina
claro a nicolás le doy unos segunditos
pac para que usted pueda tomar un sorbo
de su mate que tiene ahí para que pueda
tomar un poco de aire también mientras
le formuló la siguiente pregunta porque
esto me lleva a pensar que tal vez es
momento para que los países piensen en
apostarle un poco más a la industria
local no estar dependiendo tanto de
productos extranjeros y apostarle a
desarrollar algunos productos digamos de
alta tecnología porque no en la región
de américa latina' supongamos como por
poner un ejemplo puede ser una coyuntura
para reactivar el consumo local para
reactivar la industria local o eso
cuesta mucho tiempo a activarlo para
poder suplir el mercado
puede ser una oportunidad las coyunturas
críticas en general como esta son
instancias en las cuales se abre el
abanico de oportunidades y se replantean
algunas cosas que hasta el momento se
daban por ciertas se daban como hechas
entonces esto puede ser una costura
crítica que genere un re balance hacia
otro tipo de organización de la
producción recordemos que antes de todos
estos fenómenos que estamos analizando
en muchos casos el costo de los fletes
en el costo del transporte entre
distintas ciudades de américa latina y
puertos como lay and light era menor el
costo del transporte que puede tener
lugar por ejemplo entre un país como
uruguay un país como colombia como
ecuador eso que implica bueno eso
implica por un lado que
al apostar por un modelo en el cual este
desarrollo en cadenas más cortas
asociadas a la reindustrialización de la
región implica gestionar todo un
conjunto de desafíos asociados a la
conectividad a la logística
intrarregional y por otro lado también
implica pensar bueno cuáles son las
condiciones productivas la colaboración
público-privada para este canalizar
estas inversiones que son necesarias
para desarrollar procesos productivos
que la región ha abandonado y así bueno
poder ponerse a tiro en esta competencia
por la producción este a nivel global
que en los últimos años ha tendido a
deslocalizarse de la región verdad
nicolás américa latina ya tiene como
principal socio comercial la gran
mayoría de los países tienen como su
principal socio comercial a china por
encima incluso de eeuu que nuestro
vecino más cercano que tan dependiente
está la región del comercio con el
gigante asiático y esta coyuntura tal
vez no sirve para replantear también un
momento para diversificar mirar otros
mercados o tal vez para que otro país
con un músculo comercial y económico
como china
es tal vez pienso yo pueda ser una
oportunidad para eeuu o para la unión
europea para fortalecerse en otros
mercados
que tan dependientes estamos nosotros de
china y quienes pueden entrar a suplir
de pronto en unas semanas actuando
aprovechando la situación
bueno en particular este fenómeno se
constata a los países de américa del sur
en la gran mayoría de los países de
américa del sur el peso del comercio con
china ha superado en lo que puede ser el
peso del comercio con eeuu o como otros
socios tradicionales como la unión
europea lo cierto es que en el corto
plazo de las oportunidades para este
intercambiar socios para sustituir
socios no son este no son muy muy
elevadas en la medida que la propia
producción los propios procesos
productivos en américa del norte y en
europa occidental están muy conectados
con lo que sucede en las fábricas chinas
por lo que también es esperable en las
próximas semanas que los propios
productores europeos que los propios
productores norteamericanos empiecen a
enfrentar problemas en términos de
suministros dado este atasco que estamos
analizando por lo que en el corto plazo
yo no veo una sustitución viable que
permita américa latina' continuar
abasteciendo set frente a lo que puede
ser una mayor complejidad o incapacidad
de china de abastecer a la región en el
mediano plazo si podemos discutir otras
alternativas de organización productiva
de comercio internacional que hagan que
la región se vuelva más resiliente
frente a estos cambios y por ende estas
situaciones cada vez a desenvolverte más
frecuentes nicolás televidentes en unos
minutos vamos a conectarnos con nuestra
otra invitada para este debate y para
este análisis para seguir conversando
sobre este tema solamente denos unos
minutos y ya vamos a estar conversando
con ella también para ampliar un poco el
espectro aquí de opiniones y de puntos
de vista mientras tanto seguimos
conversando con nicolás que está
conectado desde la ciudad de montevideo
en la república oriental del uruguay
hablábamos de esa dependencia
con china que sectores desde su
perspectiva en nicolás se van a ver más
afectados por este parón de la operación
en el puerto de shanghai hay algún
sector en específico que se vaya a ver
afectado a nivel global y en nuestra
región en américa latina'
bueno a nivel global la gran mayoría de
los sectores industriales se van a ver
afectados a la medida que un montón de
insumos un montón de componentes o un
montón de procesos que terminan en el
ensamblaje en plantas chinas se van a
ver afectados por este parón en la
región uno tendería a pensar
rápidamente en la afectación este
potencialmente negativa que esto puede
tener para los productores de materias
primas para los productores de alimentos
para los productores de minerales que
exportan estos productos a china y que
pueden llegar a tener dificultades para
ingresar sus productos al mercado este
asiático al mercado chino en particular
dada la buena la incapacidad del puerto
de shanghai de gestionar estos volúmenes
como lo hacía hasta el momento a su vez
en la medida que esto afecte a la
economía china en su conjunto que afecte
el ritmo de crecimiento de la economía
china en su conjunto esto puede afectar
a la demanda china de estos productos y
por ende también puede afectar
negativamente a los precios de las
materias primas que exporta la región
así que el efecto este negativo más más
saliente en el corto plazo lo veo por
ese lado claro que si mi cola es
importante esa aclaración no le doy unos
minutos para que se tome un respiro
tomarse otro sorbo de mates yo le doy la
bienvenida a lina luna ella es sinóloga
internacionalista de la universidad
externado de colombia se conecta con
nosotros desde la ciudad de bogotá con
quien vamos a conversar desde otra
óptica este tema de suma importancia
como lo hemos visto para la economía y
para el comercio internacional por esto
también tiene otros alcances lina
bienvenida al programa muchas gracias
por atendernos
a esta hora aquí en france 24
quiero agradecerle por haberse conectado
con nosotros tan rápido y comenzar por
preguntarle por lo que significa para
china tener a su principal puerto de
exportación
prácticamente en los mínimos de
operación lo que significa esto para la
economía del país y lo que significa
para la confianza del mercado y para las
autoridades chinas que ya se la han
jugado el todo por el todo en su lucha
contra el kobe 19 ahora enfrentan este
problema de escala mundial
si básicamente esta no es una decisión
fácil pero por otro lado nos está
mostrando también un gobierno que tiene
claro que primero está la salud y la
vida de las personas antes que el tema
económico sin que esto signifique poner
en jaque como tal la economía global
como una intención es decir si hay una
economía fuerte que tiene una capacidad
de maniobra digamos un
una fortaleza muy grande es la economía
china por su precisamente es un modelo
económico donde hay una alta presencia
del estado hay buenas reservas y hay
buena capacidad de adaptación entonces
xi jinping está confiando en esta
capacidad de adaptación y es el mensaje
un poco que ha enviado al mundo les ha
dicho si estamos en un momento de
confinamiento estamos en un momento
donde se está viendo afectada la
economía pero en el caso de china
recordemos que en el caso de contención
del comité hay dos opciones una opción
de permitir el cohete
digamos esparcirse
y entonces eso hace que el control del
hobbit se dé más en el largo plazo y no
en el corto plazo pero eso termina
afectando en el largo plazo mucho más la
economía la postura china es una ruptura
rápida corta sustanciosa que permita
controlar la enfermedad para reactivar
la economía rápidamente es decir en
lugar de que sea un proceso lento y
largo es un proceso corto y se espera
que sea rápido entonces eso fue lo
primero que hicieron cuando fue la
primera bola de la pandemia en el 2020 y
es un poco lo que están intentando hacer
ahora entonces china todavía confía en
su capacidad de restablecer y digamos la
economía global y la economía china pero
en este momento les está dando prioridad
a contener el kobe a pesar de los costos
que eso tiene pero es una aproximación
de hacer un golpe fuerte corto y
sustancioso que luego permita una
reactivación económica sostenible en el
tiempo y una justamente lo decía yo en
la introducción del programa que es un
balance muy difícil es que tienen que
estar
tratando de hacer las autoridades en
beijing atender a estos 25 millones de
habitantes shanghai ya lo decíamos no es
la única ciudad que está en
confinamiento es tal vez la que ha
tenido el confinamiento más riguroso
pero hay otro centenar de ciudades que
están en la misma situación y
garantizar el funcionamiento del puerto
para engranar en el comercio
internacional que es un pedido casi que
de la comunidad internacional al unísono
para poder reactivar las economías esto
a nivel político qué implicaciones tiene
para el partido a nivel de la sociedad
estas restricciones este cierre el
impacto que va a tener económicamente
para los ciudadanos chinos al interior
hablemos del interior del país línea
bueno aquí hay que tener en cuenta que
cuando estamos hablando de la sociedad
china estamos hablando de una sociedad
confuciana y dentro de esta visión
confuciana el bien común prima sobre el
bien individual entonces de alguna
manera eso es culturalmente no es un
atropello si es decir se entiende que a
veces es necesario hacer un sacrificio
individual por un bien común no en ese
sentido es muy diferente a occidente
donde nosotros ponemos en lo individual
por encima de lo colectivo entonces en
ese sentido no es una sorpresa como tal
es decir china muchas veces ha hecho
confinamientos más pequeños más
controlados se entiende la magnitud del
hobbit y se entiende lo que puede
suceder de hecho estaríamos hablando si
china no tomara esta política de kobe
pero estaríamos hablando de millones de
personas muertas estamos hablando de un
país de 1400 millones de personas lo que
china ahorro en muertes al haber
manejado el coi de esta política de
estar con esta de esta manera fue
impresionante entonces por un lado la
población agradece y es consciente de
que pues se está poniendo la salud por
encima de todo lo que no significa que
no estén muy molestos con más bien lo
que está pasando en términos de la falta
de alimentos
por ejemplo en shanghai el confinamiento
en algunos sectores se dio en horas es
decir mientras que en unas ciudades
dijeron el lunes entramos en
confinamiento el shanghai fue hoy a las
4 de la tarde entonces eso le dio muy
poco tiempo a las personas para
prepararse para este confinamiento y en
ese sentido esa sorpresa llevó a unos
grandes problemas logísticos en términos
de alimentación de organización de
abastecimiento los chinos por ejemplo en
sus costumbres de compra no son como por
ejemplo somos los latinos que hacemos la
compra del mes grandota y tenemos
reservas guardadas los chinos casi que
compran lo del día sí entonces es esa
costumbre en este momento cuando los
tomó por sorpresa al confinamiento pues
no les dio un tiempo suficiente de
abastecimiento y eso está provocando
estos problemas de alimentación por
ejemplo en shanghai entonces la molestia
está más destinada a
como va a ser el gobierno para
para atacar estos estos asuntos
logísticos que sabemos entienden el
confinamiento entienden la medida la
valoran y la aprueban pero los temas
logísticos con alimentación y con poder
salir lo más pronto posible del
confinamiento son los temas que
preocupan más a la sociedad china en
este momento que eso es lo que ha dado
paso a algunas protestas el descontento
en los ciudadanos allí en la ciudad de
shanghai que hemos visto imágenes de
personas que se enfrentan a las
autoridades o personas que son sacadas a
la fuerza de sus casas para ser llevados
a centros para ser atendidos porque
tienen que aislar una zona en específico
y pues el desabastecimiento que se
empezó a presentar en algunos
supermercados al inicio de este
confinamiento nicolás no me olvido de
usted ya voy a volver con usted para
conversar de temas económicos para
seguir analizando este tema interesante
desde todos los puntos de vista y quiero
preguntarle en nicolás
estamos a semanas entonces de empezar a
experimentar una inflación alta en
américa latina y países que están
presentando cifras verdaderamente
complicadas complejas y que las
economías todavía no están despegando
esto para la región
en que se va a traducir entonces aumento
de pobreza aumento de precios al mediano
plazo cuál es el análisis que se puede
hacer
bueno en el corto plazo eso es un
desafío el aumento de la inflación que
ya viene registrando una aceleración con
respecto a años previos si se quiere un
asterisco o
un elemento que puede atenuar un poco el
impacto sobre fenómenos como la pobreza
que tú mencionabas o sobre bueno las
condiciones de vida de la población en
general es que el precio de los
alimentos en la medida que china es un
gran productor de casi todo salvo
alimentos un gran exportador de casi
todos algo alimentos bueno tal vez en
los precios de los alimentos no se vean
tan afectados y eso pueda contener un
poco estos fenómenos inflacionarios o al
menos el impacto sobre las poblaciones
latinoamericanas sobre todas las
poblaciones más vulnerables al
incremento de precios de alimentos es
por ese lado uno podría imaginar si se
quiere una inflación pero no tan acotada
y no tan asociada a la provisión de
estos productos básicos que bueno que a
veces son los que ponen en mayor tensión
a la ciudadanía o al menos a la
ciudadanía más vulnerable en el mediano
plazo
uno tiene que evaluar o estimar cuál va
a ser el efecto de esto sobre la
economía china para poder entender y
para poder proyectar cuál puede ser el
impacto en américa latina' en la medida
que esto efectivamente afecte a la
economía china el crecimiento proyectado
para el agro china este año el año el
año próximo bueno eso efectivamente va a
poner presión va a poner tensión sobre
las exportaciones en nuestros países
sobre las exportaciones en los países
latinoamericanos que como mencionábamos
en intervenciones anteriores se
concentran cada vez más en socios como
china por lo que una reducción de la
demanda de los productos que la región
exporta al gigante asiático bueno pueden
poner este en tensión los saldos de
cuenta corriente y los saldos de balanza
comercial de nuestros países y también
la capacidad de generar divisas
necesarias para pagar las importaciones
del resto de los de los bienes y
servicios que consumimos en la región y
con las que hay de otros puertos en la
región que no están muy lejos de
shanghai bueno el continente asiático es
inmenso y las distancias son enormes
pero pero mirándolo en el mapa a puertos
como por ejemplo hong kong o singapur
podrían llegar a reemplazar en estas
cadenas de abastecimiento en singapur
siempre ha sido un puerto eficiente
rápido un punto estratégico en el
estrecho de malaca pero hong kong está
tal vez podría volverse temporalmente
esa puerta de salida que necesita china
para sus para sus exportaciones
puede ser una opción pero parece difícil
en el corto plazo pueda sustituir la
totalidad o el grueso del volumen de
negocios que maneja el puerto de
shanghai como tú bien comentaba en la
introducción es el mayor puerto del
mundo en la actualidad es un puerto que
por ejemplo para el comercio granelero
que es parte de las exportaciones
sistemas fuertes que tiene américa
latina-asia hacia china es el principal
punto de ingreso de estos bienes hacia
hacia el territorio chino por lo que
parcialmente pueden ser sustitutos pero
me cuesta imaginar que en el corto plazo
al menos este puedan absorber
completamente la operativa comercial que
hasta entonces tenía lugar en shanghai
también dependerá de las estrategias del
gobierno chino de como el gobierno chino
e internamente lograré canalizar
determinados volúmenes del comercio
hacia otros puntos como por ejemplo el
puerto de hong kong o otros puertos que
en donde en ciudades donde el
confinamiento tal vez no sea tan
estricto pero bueno ellos al día de hoy
es una incertidumbre no no sabemos a
ciencia cierta cuál es la capacidad de
efectivamente implementar este tipo de
medidas
lina en términos políticos esta crisis
comercial y esta este gran peso que
tiene el gobierno chino en este momento
por mantener la salud de los habitantes
de estas ciudades a salvo del
coronavirus y tratar de responder un
poco a la comunidad internacional con
este tema comercial desvía china de
otros temas importantes de la coyuntura
internacional donde la comunidad
internacional le pide a china estar
presente temas por ejemplo la invasión a
ucrania por parte de rusia la atención
que con eeuu la atención reciente que
entre de corea del norte de eeuu por los
lanzamientos de misiles por parte del
régimen de pyongyang ese tipo de
coyunturas internacionales en donde
siempre se pide que china de pronto de
su punto de vista su opinión la aleja un
poco esta coyuntura que está viviendo
lina bueno creo que se congeló un poco
la conexión con lina en la ciudad de
bogotá más adelante entonces retomaremos
este tema con ella para seguir
analizando esta pregunta que le estaba
haciendo a nuestra invitada sobre la
importancia de china en otras coyunturas
internacionales como por ejemplo la
guerra en ucrania o esa tensión
comercial que mantiene con eeuu que no
disminuye pese a los intentos de ambos
lados por tratar de conversar un poco
más distensión ado entre los dos
gobiernos pero tal parece que china toma
una posición de distanciarse un poco de
esos temas internacionales para
concentrarse en esta crisis interna que
tiene con este rebrote de covite sino
que como decíamos es uno de los más
fuertes desde el inicio de la pandemia
me confirma que ya tenemos a lina otra
vez conectada a la ciudad de bogotá
línea delante
bueno hay definitivamente la tecnología
no está del lado de nosotros para el
programa entonces paso a preguntarle a
nicolás en la ciudad de montevideo para
seguir ampliando este tema desde el
punto de vista económico desde el
alcance que pueda tener este este parón
este freno en las cadenas de suministro
y en el comercio internacional
eeuu actor importante nicolás para el
comercio internacional también cómo
puede aprovechar esta oportunidad
bueno eeuu tal vez intenté subrayar o
ilustrar algunas de las debilidades o
algunas de los de los riesgos asociados
a este una mayor dependencia de la
región de china lo cierto es que en el
corto plazo como decíamos la producción
estadounidense se encuentra muy
integrada en cadenas con la producción
china por lo que la capacidad de eeuu de
sustituir parte de los bienes y
servicios que sobre todo de bienes que
la región se abastece desde china es
limitada pero bueno la medida que esto
se prolongue esté allí puede generarse
otra ventana de oportunidad como la que
hablábamos anterior para anteriormente
para la reindustrialización de la región
habrá que ver pues la magnitud de este
parón en el mediano plazo
algunos análisis te manejan que mediados
de mayo podrían estar este
reorganizándose las cadenas atrás bueno
un aflojamiento de lo que son las
condiciones de confinamiento actuales en
shanghai no lo sabemos a ciencia cierta
pero si eso es una realidad que en la
medida que esto se prolonga en el tiempo
de que china mantenga su política de
kobe 0 este en períodos más prolongados
bueno si se abra un debate para
distintas alternativas y así la política
internacional también entra está zar
nicolás me desvió un poco de esta
coyuntura de
este cierre temporal de buena parte del
puerto de shanghai para preguntarle por
su país por uruguay un país que
aparentemente es una economía muy
pequeña pero es un país que está
haciendo un gran esfuerzo precisamente
para acercarse a china y está buscando
un tratado de libre comercio que le ha
generado un poco de controversia al
interior del mercosur como avance esa
cercanía entre montevideo y beijing
cuántos pasos ha dado así al frente
uruguay en esta negociación cómo va eso
bueno sabemos que hace un tiempo el
gobierno uruguayo anunció el inicio de
un estudio de prefactibilidad conjunto
con el gobierno chino para avanzar hacia
lo que sería una posterior negociación
de un acuerdo de libre comercio
bilateral eso choca con la disposición
del mercosur uruguay forma parte de
negociar este lo que son acuerdos de
comercio preferencial el acuerdo de
libre comercio con terceros de forma
conjunta el gobierno uruguayo ha tomado
la estrategia de avanzar por su cuenta
en la medida que se encuentra un socio
como china aparentemente dispuesto a
negociar pero lo cierto es que desde ese
anuncio desde el inicio de un estudio de
prefactibilidad conjunto que ya tiene un
buen tiempo no hemos tenido mayores
novedades al respecto los socios de la
región este tanto argentina como brasil
se muestran escépticos sobre la
posibilidad de que uruguay pueda
establecer un acuerdo bilateral con
china el gobierno chino no sabemos hasta
qué punto tienen intenciones este serias
de avanzar en este camino o si lo ha
anunciado o si no vende un anuncio que
luego no no ha tenido un desarrollo este
como tal es algo que no esperaba pero lo
cierto es que la medida que esto avance
en uruguay se enfrentará el dilema de
priorizar sus vínculos bilaterales con
china o de priorizar sus vínculos con la
región y así el resultado es incierto
también un balance difícil para las
autoridades uruguayas linas ya tenemos
otra desconexión con usted está de nuevo
aquí con nosotros y le preguntaba
entonces por el aspecto más político y a
nivel internacional repito entonces
brevemente la pregunta se aleja china de
la coyuntura que estamos viviendo guerra
en ucrania la atención con corea del
norte esas discrepancias con washington
por estar enfocada en este tema
comercial y en la salud de sus
habitantes
bueno ahí es otra oportunidad también
para ver más bien el la fortaleza del
gobierno chino y la maniobra
maniobrabilidad del gobierno chino en
diferentes aspectos la política exterior
de china es de un respeto total de
absoluto a la soberanía de otros países
y eso ha sido muy coherente con la
postura china frente a temas como
precisamente corea del norte como el
tema de ucrania etcétera etcétera y
hemos visto a una china por un lado
defensora de sus principios por un lado
una una china que no se deja manipular
en el sentido de que si es como no no no
va a declarar cosas que no quiere
declarar y no se va a meter donde no se
quiere meter ni va a tomar partido donde
no quiere tomar partido y también vemos
una china coherente con el principio de
que la prioridad es china y sus
habitantes antes que otras cosas es
decir no caer ante presiones
internacionales entonces no más que una
china que enfoque más el énfasis en
adentro que afuera vamos a ver que hay
una sección del gobierno muy enfocada en
el tema del comit pero no por eso china
va a dejar de poner atención a los otros
temas lo que pasa es que en los otros
temas china ha sido muy clara también
eso de no involucrarse más allá de lo
necesario
y permitir que los países como que vayan
haciendo lo que tienen que hacer
entonces más bien aquí vemos un gobierno
bastante coherente con su política
exterior y con su política interior y
realmente por como te explicaba antes yo
creo que esto no va a durar mucho tiempo
el modelo de shanghai es decir es una es
una terapia de choque digamos no desde
hacer un cierre rápido con tener rápido
y rápidamente salir del asunto para
reaccionar la economía china ya activó
hace un tiempo también de con sucede
decimocuarto plan quinquenal una cosa
que ellos llaman el plan de circulación
dual es decir la de milán en la economía
china ya venía cerrando sí un poco
enfocándose en unos aspectos internos y
diciéndole a los países hacia fuera voy
a cambiar las cadenas de suministro y
las cadenas de valor entonces muchas
economías también ya estaban en ese
proceso de adaptarse a estas nuevas
demandas de china entonces creo que eso
sigue sigue sigue sucediendo y que
esperemos que no se alargue mucho pero
en términos internacionales por más de
que presionen pues si nada
y si la historia fuera el otro lado la
moneda que china no hubiera confinado
tuviera el puerto abierto y se estuviera
esparciendo el hobbit nuevamente por el
planeta el reclamo de la comunidad
internacional al gobierno de china sería
otra historia completamente diferente a
nicolás en la ciudad de montevideo le
agradezco muchísimo por este completo
análisis en materia económica creo que
en palabras muy simples nos explicó lo
que significa este este cierre del
puerto de shanghai a lina mil gracias
por haberse conectado con nosotros y
habernos explicado estos puntos de vista
interesantes ustedes pueden seguir
participando dejando sus comentarios y
sus preguntas muchas gracias
[Música]